I'm not going to do too much on Donald Trump's
recent interviews, but there is one interview
that I think deserves some discussion.
Donald Trump this morning was very late
to what could be could be his last Fox News
interview as a non lame duck president. Trump
did a handful of rallies yesterday and didn't
make it back to the White House until very late.
He was expected on Fox News bright and early this
morning on Fox and Friends. He just didn't appear
on time. The belief is he slept through it.
Eventually, Trump called in 40 minutes late
or something like that sounded terrible. But
more importantly, his closing message was a
disgusting and humiliating one. Take a look at
some of these clips. Of course, the rumor has
been Trump is planning to declare victory if
he has any path to possible victory tonight,
even if he hasn't won. Asked about it, Trump says,
I will declare victory when there is victory.
Sounds like he has a frog in his throat. Sounds
down. Sounds depressed. Sounds sort of resigned.
So, Mr. President, the analysis of what they're
talking about and some of the things you've said,
they are suggesting that you may declare victory
if the early numbers favor you. At what point will
you declare victory when there's victory?
If there's victory? I think. I think we'll
have victory. I think the polls are, you know,
suppression polls. And I think we'll have victory,
but only when there's victory. I mean, there's a
reason to play games. And I think what victory I
think was, you know, I look at it as being a very,
very solid chance at winning. I don't know what
the chances are or how they read the chances. But
I think we have a very solid chance of winning.
So many people heard that and thought, oh, that's
reassuring, right? He will only declare victory
when there's victory. The problem with Trump is he
believes he will win, period. And what happens if
the numbers don't support that position at this
point? It's not even worth speculating. We will
know soon. Let's just wait and see. Trump at one
point saying it's been a great run, which for a
moment sounded almost like a farewell tour. And
we've been seeing this now for the last five or
six days, which is Trump still insists we will
win. We're ahead everywhere, that there aren't
suppression polls. We're winning, winning, winning
everywhere. But then he'll have these five, 10,
20 second moments where he sounds almost like
he's saying goodbye. This was one of them.
And it's been you know, it's been an and
it's been a great it's been a great run.
Then Donald Trump again suggesting that all of
these boat owners who support him are a signal
that how could he lose the boaters, the debt, the
people with boats in Florida's intercoastal and
other places, they love me. And so I will win.
Oh, it's different places. And you've seen the
boats. The boats are, you know, six thousand
votes at a lake. And we're going for records.
I mean, lesson one, when
people with boats support you.
How can you lose? Right. Well, let's let's
see, then. Fox and Friends host Ainsley Earhart
sets Trump up by talking about how mean everybody
is to him. This is one of the three major,
major cable news networks interviewing
a president with a record of 20000 lies
and absolute immoral, negligent mishandling of 100
year global pandemic. And Ainslee, I heard this,
Mr. President, talk about how they're mean
to you. This is how they do it. Take a look.
You know, they say that. And when they say they
love you, I like how you say why. I love you,
too. Because when you love someone, that's always
nice to hear back. But what has it been like? Have
you love the job or is it has it been worth
it because you've been under so much attack?
Well, it's been. I mean, it's been you've
dealt with horrible people are shifty,
sheriff, crazy Nancy and Granger. Chuck
Schumer, you deal with some horrible people,
really hard hitting stuff hard, guys.
Shocking. Trump was even able to answer
these questions then. This was just a weird
moment. Donald Trump bizarrely claimed
that the United States is
more difficult to deal with
than Russia or North Korea. Almost as if the U.S.
is a foreign country. He's dealing with. I don't.
I don't know how to make heads or tails out of.
This is just a weird thing to say. Take a look.
But it's you deal with people that are very
deceptive. But they'll go. Mr. President, tell me,
who is the country that's most difficult
to deal with? Is it Russia? Is it China?
Is it North Korea? Sir, as North Korea and I got
to know, well, by far the most difficult country
to deal with is the US. It's not even close.
Yeah, just a really strange direction. And then
this is maybe my favorite moment from the entire
interview. Donald Trump attacks Fox News while
on Fox News and says, you know, Fox changed. Fox
has been airing Biden's speeches lately. And it's
so it's a beautiful moment. It's a poetic moment
because Fox News ends up having to defend itself
to the president. It's up just a great moment.
Take a look. If this is if this is the end for
Trump, this is just a great moment to go
out on, Bush said on the stump before.
Right. Mr. Pres, I know you've said on the stump
before, I wouldn't have gotten into this job. I
ran for this job if the previous administration
wasn't, in your words, so bad. And some have said
that Barack Obama's come out to be the bad cop
to go after you. One of the things he said last
night was he's going around spreading Colvard like
he's a carrier because he cares more about having
these big crowds. They does. Keeping people safe.
Do you want to respond to the former president?
Well, fortunately, he is drawing flies. He's not
getting anybody to go. Isn't too much. Actually,
Fox puts him on more than anybody else, which
is sort of shock into Meeker's. Fox has changed
a lot. And somebody said, what's the biggest
difference between this and four years ago? And
I say, Fox, it's much different. You still have
great people, but you're here, three of them.
But you know, Mr. President, can I just
say one thing? They tried to do what
they tried to do with Fox in terms of
what we just want to show for written.
Unlike other networks, they were trying to
show both sides. So, hey, here's President
Trump live. Here's Joe Biden life because we
built a response to sell when we report. Yeah.
So I don't think it's an endorsement of
anybody when FOX News hosts have to explain
to the president that, you know, we have
to acknowledge that you have an opponent
and we have to mention that your opponent is
campaigning. It's not an endorsement. You know,
things have gotten really bad in the country
when that's something that the president has
to be explained like a little kid. And then
a final closing message from from Trump,
a moment of unity and of bringing people together.
Trump says it would be terrible for for women,
for Kamala Harris to be the vice
president of the United States.
Sharpton, if he does, he's not going to be
there very long. He's got a vice president who's
further left than Bernie Sanders, who
is not a particularly good person.
And she would be, I think, a terrible first
representative. If she if she became the first
woman president, I think it would
be a terrible thing for our country,
I think would be a terrible thing for women.
So there it is, Donald Trump's last
pre-election call into Fox and Friends, and
hopefully any future calls will be as lame
duck. But we have to make it happen tonight. I
will be live YouTube twitch and Facebook starting
moments before the seven p.m. results come in.
Don't miss it. Join me then. Just short of
7:00 p.m. Eastern Time. Very big night ahead of
us. The David Pakman Show David Pakman dadgum.